NOW RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
PUTIN IS MAKING A RARE PUBLIC
APPEARANCE, SAYING THE ARMED
FORCES ARE SPECIFICALLY
TARGETING UKRAINE'S ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT ACCUSES UKRAINE OF, QUOTE,
STARTING IT.
BLAMING --
FOR BROUGHT BLOWING UP A BRIDGE
TO CRIMEA AND ATTACKING AN
AIRFIELD IN KURSK, INSIDE.
RUSSIA UKRAINE HAS NOT OFFERED
COMMENTS ON EITHER OF THOSE
INCIDENTS.
SAM KILEY JOINS US NOW IN
KRAMATORSK IN EASTERN UKRAINE.
SAM, INTERESTING EMISSION
THERE.
AND OF, COURSE ONE COULD MAKE
THE ARGUMENT THAT RUSSIA'S LONG
AWAITED TO TARGETED CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN UKRAINE, LONG
BEFORE THAT ATTACK TOOK PLACE
IN CRIMEA.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IN UKRAINE --
ANYBODY WAS WHAT UKRAINE A RUN
IN UKRAINE WHEN THESE --
RAIN DOWN IN MARKEDLY FIVE YOU
ARE IN KHARKIV AND MARIUPOL,
WHICH WERE FLATTENED.
THE IDEA THAT THE UKRAINIANS
ARE SOMEHOW PROVOKING RUSSIAN
IRE INTO RELUCTANTLY ATTACKING
THE ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE OF
THE COUNTRY IS ABSURD.
I TALK INDIAN INFRASTRUCTURE OF
A COUNTRY, TRYING TO TOPPLE ITS
GOVERNMENT, WHICH HAS INVADED
AND STOLEN LARGE CHUNKS OF ITS
LAND, MAKES SENSE.
IT MAY BE, THAT IT MAY BE A
VIOLATION OF INTELLECTUAL
HUMANITARIAN LAW.
BUT IT MAKES SENSE MILITARILY.
SURPRISE IT DIDN'T HAPPEN
SOONER.
BUT IT IS CERTAINLY NOT IN
RESPONSE TO UKRAINE'S ATTACKS
AGAINST THE MILITARY TARGETS.
OR TARGETS WITH MILITARY
CIVILIAN UNITS SUCH AS THE
BRIDGE, THAT IS A LEGALLY
CONNECTING RUSSIA TO THE
CRIMEAN PENINSULA.
JULIA, YEAH.
AN ABSURD CLAIM.
OVER THE LAST 24 HOURS, HE HAS
ALSO REPEATED HIS --
TO USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME HE IS, AND
WE ARE NOT MAD.
WE DO NOT GO AROUND THE WORLD
HOLDING THE NUCLEAR KNIFE TO
PEOPLE'S THROATS.
THOUGH, ACTUALLY, IN THE PAST,
HE HAS DONE PRECISELY.
THAT POTENTIALLY THE USE OF
RUSSIAN NUCLEAR WEAPONS, WHICH
IS HELD BACK A LOT OF THE
ADDITIONAL HELP THE UKRAINIANS
WERE ASKING FOR FROM NATO.
NATO IS VERY ANXIOUS ABOUT AN
ILLEGAL RESPONSE, TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS BEING USED
AGAINST UKRAINE OR PERHAPS MORE
WIDELY.
THIS SORT OF LANGUAGE IS ALL
PART OF PUTIN'S EFFORTS TO SORT
OF STIR THE POT.
IT CONTINUES THE ARGUMENT.
AND HE IS VERY GOOD AT IT.
>> HE DID STEP BACK A LITTLE
FROM THAT, THERE.
AND IT ON YOU IN TERMS OF THE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, THAT THEY'RE
USED FOR DEFENSIVE PURPOSES.
ONE CAN MAKE THAT ARGUMENT,
TOO.
AGAIN, TO YOUR POINT, IT IS A
SORT OF FLEXING OF MUSCLE.
>> IT IS THE HOT, COLD, HOT,
COLD.
ONE MINUTE HE SAYS HE THINKS
THAT THEY MAY USE IT.
I MENTIONS IT AGAIN.
BUT SOMETHING SIMILAR MIGHT DO
SO.
BUT IT IS ALL PART OF THIS
ONGOING HORROR.
ON THE GROUND, JULIA, THINGS
ARE GETTING INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT.
WHERE IRRATIONALLY IT MAY BE
THAT THE RUSSIANS ARE THROWING
ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF ENERGY IN
TO THAT COMMUTE.
WE RECENTLY GAINED HOSPITALS,
UNIQUELY, REALLY, TO THE
MILITARY HOSPITAL THERE.
THINGS ARE EXTREMELY DIFFICULT.
>> ALL-TIME BRAIN SURGERY IN
TANDEM.
WOUNDED IN BATTLE ON THE SAME,
DAY ON THE SAME FRONT.
TWO YOUNG MEN, THE --
OF THESE OVER PRACTICE
NEUROSURGEONS.
KRAMATORSK IS OFTEN CALLED.
THIS THE WINDOWS, EVEN IN, HERE
A TAPE TO SLOW FLYING GLASS THE
EFFORT IS INTENDS TO.
REPAIR BRAINS, SAVE LIVES,
MEMORIES LABS AND FUTURE DREAMS.
THEY WOULD HAVE LITTLE IDEA
WHERE TO START THEIR.
WHERE IF THEY DID NOT HAVE USE
OF THIS CT SCANNER.
IT CAN PINPOINT DAMAGE, FIND
WHAT IT HAS DONE, AND IT GIVES
SURGEONS A PLAN OF ACTION.
HE SAYS, YES, AND UNFORTUNATELY
THERE IS NO LEFT EYE.
THERE IS A SUM SUBMISSION OF
THAT, BUT DEFINITELY NO LEFT I.
>> THIS IS THE FOURTH PATIENT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE SPACE OF
ABOUT AN HOUR COME IN FOR A CT
SCAN.
IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE DOING 15
OR 20 A DAY.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING 70 OR
80.
IN SHORT, IT IS WEARING OUT.
>> THIS EQUIPMENT IS VITAL.
THE HOSPITAL CANNOT AFFORD A
NEW ONE.
THERE ARE USED ONES FOR SALE IN
WESTERN UKRAINE THAT COST ABOUT
$120,000.
THE PRICE OF LOSING THIS ONE,
INCALCULABLE.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> HE SAYS HE SHOWS SIGNS OF
SEVERE CRANIAL CEREBRAL INJURY,
WITH ACUTE SUBDERMAL HEMATOMA
AND SEVERE BRAIN CONTUSION.
HE NEEDS URGENT SURGERY.
THE ADMINISTRATORS HERE HAVE
RAISED ABOUT $60,000.
THEY NEED HELP WITH THE REST.
THIS IS THE ONLY CT SCANNER IN
A VAST REGION.
CRITICAL, THIS MACHINE IS
CRITICAL.
CT IS CRITICAL TO PROVIDING
APPROPRIATE CARE FOR PATIENTS
WITH BOTH HEAD WOUNDS AND ACUTE
BRAIN INJURIES.
>> IS IT SAVING LIVES?
>> DEFINITELY, ABSOLUTELY,
100%.
>> THERE'S BEEN A STEADY FLOW
OF SOLDIERS INJURED IN AND NEAR
BAKHMUT.
THAT IS THE SCENE OF THE
HEAVIEST FIGHTING.
THIS IS A HOSPITAL THAT IS
TRYING TO DEAL REALLY WITH AN
AREA THEY SAY IS ABOUT 300
SQUARE KILOMETERS, AND A LOT OF
THAT IS AT WAR.
>> SOME SOLDIERS ARE RELATIVELY
LUCKY.
DUCK WAS RELATIVELY LUCKY,
SHOOTING MORTARS AT THE
RUSSIANS, WHO SHOT MORTARS
BACK.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> MY COMMANDER WAS LUCKY.
HE SAT IN FRONT OF ME, AND I
SAT BEHIND HIM.
AND HE WAS UNHURT.
I GOT HIT IN THE LEG.
BUT YEAH, WE HAVE SEEN WOUNDED
AND DEAD BEFORE.
IF I AM SITTING HERE, I AM
LUCKY.
UKRAINIANS ON THIS EASTERN
FRONT CALL IT THE MEAT GRINDER.
JACK WAS ALONGSIDE DUCK WHEN
THEY WERE HIT.
>> HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THE
BATTLE FOR BAKHMUT?
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> HE SAID WORLD WAR I,
TRENCHES, MUD, BLOOD, TRENCHES,
MUD AGAIN,, ARTILLERY, TRENCH
WARFARE.
THAT'S IT, WORLD WAR I, WORLD
WAR II.
VERDUN, THE SOMME, SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT MODERN
WEAPONS ARE NOW MORE POWERFUL.
MODERN SURGERY, OFTEN THE ONLY
ROUTE FOR SURVIVAL.
THAT, AND OLD-FASHIONED GRIT.
>> NOW, JULIA, THE UKRAINIANS
ARE INDEED SHOWING A LOT OF
GRIT AND HOLDING THE RUSSIANS
BACK FROM BAKHMUT.
WE, BATTLING THE, IT IS QUITE
WHY THE RUSSIANS ARE DOING.
IT DOESN'T HAVE SPECIFIC
STRATEGIC VALUE IS THE
ASSUMPTION ON THE UKRAINIAN
SIDE IS THAT PUTIN NEEDS SOME
KIND OF A VICTORY AFTER MONTHS
OF BATTLEFIELD LOSSES.
>> SAM KILEY, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
WHEN INCREDIBLE ACCESS IN THAT
REPORT.
SAM KILEY, THERE IN KRAMATORSK.